uh andy preston welcome to spectator tv
you know so much of this coverage comes
out of the westminster bubble
uh but here you are on spectator tv the
mayor of middlesbrough
how does it look from where you sit and
how does the government's response
look um so what it looks from where we
sit
is there is a situation where people are
non-plussed i mean as
i think everybody said earlier this this
this thing was predicted to have uh
caused mayhem and killed lots of people
and what most people know is that
statistically the virus is spreading but
most people don't yet
know anybody who's died i think we have
to take it incredibly
nobody knows what's ahead of us by the
way with infections hospitalizations
and mortality but absolutely uh
professor namara is spot on
we need to find a way of working with
this and what happened
last week was westminster the government
said to middlesbrough and other places
we are going to do something to you
we're not going to work with you we're
not going to listen to local knowledge
we're not going to look at local data
we're going to do something to you we're
going to effectively
close down your your food and beverage
business plunging
thousands of people into unemployment
and the corresponding
economic impact the physical health that
meant if i may say
uh as a 54 year old who grew up in the
in the 80s left school in 82
the industrial recession then was
terrifying
and and middlesbrough council our tiny
unity authority is still paying
probably about 15 million quid a year
in child care in social health in all
kinds of ways
paying for the way that that industrial
recession was handled 35 years ago so
we've spent
hundreds of millions and what we need to
do now is as other people have said is
look at this
problem as a not just a covert numbers
problem
but a physical health a mental health
and a long-term economic shock
and i fear i fear that what we're
looking at is how do we get the numbers
down get the numbers down get the
numbers down
and to use the whack-a-mole analogy um i
fear boris johnson is
whacking the same mole when the others
are popping up
so i think there's a sense that we are a
victim
again there's a sense we aren't being
consulted or listened to and there's a
sense that the government is doing stuff
to us
without giving us a chance to explain
why they might be able to do it better
so your heart must sink then at the
prospect of more lockdown measures
coming in because that's all the buzz
out of the government
it's just they can't quite it seems
can't quite make up their mind
exactly what they should be it's become
incredibly complicated
they're saying it may not come into
monday we're ready for a thursday uh
now it would seem that the government is
set on a course off which you don't
approve
is that fair yes that is absolutely
right um i mean all the data we have
does
say that the vast majority something
like 82 percent of cases locally
are derived from inside the home
socializing at home so we need to
we actually ask for a temporary
restriction on socializing at home
but why shouldn't somebody be allowed to
stand on their garden path
and talk with a neighbor why shouldn't i
be able to take my wife for
dinner in a really well run restaurant
the risks of contracting a virus there
in a well-run establishment are
are literally minuscule and to plunge so
many people into unemployment to cause
so much mental health problems
and and store up this potential 35-year
time bomb as we had from the 80s
recession seems
bizarre at best negligent at worst and
we need to be looking at this
pragmatically i think professor nabarro
admitted that we don't know much about
this i'm not stopped on kobe by the way
i've introduced all kinds of measures
to try and deal with it but we're
learning as we go we need to try
different
things and see what works but but local
is good
we need central government and local
government to work together and that's
the bit andrew that's missing
the northern mayors um which have not
been a par
in the land since victorian times but
you are a power in the land now
and you all labour and conservative are
independent you seem to be speaking with
broadly
one voice on these things there may be
details you differ about
but as i've seen from andy burnham in
manchester for example and others
there's a broadly the same analysis and
the same criticism
coming out hasn't that cut any ice with
the government if you've got these
mayors across political parties
representing our great northern cities
hasn't that made the government think
what it looks like to me as an outsider
i'm not an insider into westminster it
looks like there's a key
group a small group that is advising has
got the era of the pm
and maybe a few others and and that is
dictating
how the pm sees and feels things um and
that's rippling out across the country
um
it's it's crazy and and what we
don't want people to do exactly what we
want but we want people to listen to
what we want
and tell us why they can't do it that
that's that's all we want
we're not listening there they're not
listening they're not listening at all
no there hasn't been a single
cl despite what you hear otherwise the
truth is there has not been
one conversation with a senior member of
government or a senior civil servant
with anybody in middlesbrough or
hartlepool in the last few weeks
yet the torah is supposed to be the
party of the north now
well i believe that there's a real will
there from the tories to level up i do
believe it as an independent i i i think
that they want to do great
things but this is this is this
is so difficult it's a crisis governing
a crisis is a nightmare
at the beginning in any crisis what
happens is everyone rallies around you
and that's what happened in the spring
loads of popularity
it's now getting frayed this is classic
crisis uh
behavior and the government's own people
are
turning on and this this could go very
very badly wrong for the government and
the country
and i think the the easy way to fix it
is start talking
start listening to a broader range of
people and start communicating
you